other two together. Therefore,
number two
number three.
Number
what is in this verse
of Allah.
Because nothing
subhanah willing it does anything happen
against the will of Allah
there was
innovation
what I've said this before
if I've said before is m
set up here you would have
a 10 volume book with at least 6 700
narrations mentioned I mean a lot of
knowledge has been passed around here
alhamdulillah this is a blessing from
Allah we were able to share these things
together but I've I've already said most
of this the first innovation in the
history of Islam
it happened during the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
But then it blew up in the time of the
companions.
It ended up being the cause of the
murder of
and then the murder of Ali and then the
attempted murder of Muawi
and it also was the
driving force behind the murder of many
companions and Muslim. What is that
innovation?
The first innovation in Islam is what?
The innovation of
Yes.
That was the first innovation in Islam.
The second innovation is in Muslim.
It is the first narration in Sah Muslim.
The narration
of Abdullahb Omar
who narrates that Omar who said that and
the narration of Gibl in which a man
came to us who had very black hair and
very white clothing and he sat very
close to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam none of us knew him and he was
it didn't look he had he was a
traveler we know the narration right the
first narration of sah Muslim
Why did that narration come about? A
group, two men of the scholars of the
came from al-Bas
and they came to make and find Omar and
ask him about this an innovation that
sprouted in.
That innovation was the innovation of
what?
Anyone know
the innovation of Aladar?
The second innovation in Islamic history
is the innovation
with regards to the people of decree.
They said they continued to to think.
And remember this came from where
you remember last night we said when we
trace when we trace innovations
we usually almost always nine times out
of 10 find that those innovations come
from where?
Muslim living as a minority amongst a
majority of disbelievers or on the
borders where the Muslim and the
disbelievers meet. The Muslim thear meet
they have that interaction.
This came from there from
and they said
[Silence]
They said to Iban Omar, "We have a
people where we come from.
They are incredibly knowledgeable."
However,
they continue to try to trace knowledge
all the way to its origins. And they
have come to the conclusion
that all of this has not been written
yet. There is no such thing as decree.
There is no such thing as or to say as a
matter of fact not as to say as a matter
of fact not only did Allah not write
this he doesn't only did Allah not write
this he doesn't even know about this
existence.
Could you imagine
that Allah didn't It's not just that
Allah didn't write it. He didn't know it
was going to happen and he still doesn't
know that this existence that this
creation exists. These are people that
called themselves Muslim and they
memorized the Quran and they made salah
and they went for
and they went in jihad.
So this is the second innovation in
Islam. Aladia.
One of the
was debating one of
and they said
they said are he said to the scholar it
was a scholar in the time of Imam Ahmed
Allah he said so you're saying Allah
that anything that happens is by the
will of Allah are you saying that Allah
willed for zena and shik
and indecency
and he responded and said are you saying
that these things occur
against the will of Allah
now it has to be one of the two either
Allah wills it or Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is forced is there anything that
forces Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
absolutely
However, just because Allah allows for
something to happen, just because he
wills for it to be in existence doesn't
mean that he
just like
we as human beings there are things
which we love innately and there are
things which we love only because of the
good that is brought by even if the
thing itself is disliked.
medicine, bitter medicine for for
instance. Aspirin one of the most
aspirin. When we go to an ice cream
vendor, do we say, "Put a little aspirin
on my on my cone?" Of course not. We
dislike the taste of aspirin. it's
immediately we dislike it, but we love
it because of the
effects that it has that can only come
about by way of that bitterness. In
order for